what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime opera and today i will be
breaking down the latest events
in the boku no hero story including
a major reveal about dobby's true
backstory and how he became the
psychotic villain that he is today
up until this point we've only had an
incomplete version
of dobby's backstory but now finally
we are getting the full version thanks
to rey todoroki
these new revelations will have a
massive impact on the entire todoroki
family
and the wider hero society so let's get
into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave a like
and comment it really does help and i'm
not
just saying that it really does help
with the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications the only way to make
sure that you won't miss our videos in
the future
is to take the time to subscribe hit the
bell and then select that option that
says
all finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the latest chapter starts off with a
flashback to the moment when rey and
angie first met
their marriage was always supposed to be
a quirk marriage
rey's father wanted his family to be
joined with the family of the hero who
was destined to become the future number
one
and of course angie wanted someone whose
quirk would be a perfect
pairing for his own rey agreed to this
arrangement for the sake of her family
and angie was determined to make this
happen so that his future children would
have the highest possible chance of
developing the kind of quirks that could
one day surpass
all might you really have to feel bad
for rey here because it really seems
like she was pressured to do this out of
a sense of duty to her family and not
because she actually wanted to
presumably she didn't even know endeavor
at this point so
obviously this was not a relationship
that was rooted in love
it was first and foremost a quirk
marriage
this idea of a quirk marriage is a very
interesting concept
and something that is unique to the
world of boku no hero
the obvious analogy to this in our own
world would be a political marriage
where
two families join together in order to
increase their wealth and influence
regardless of whether the two people
getting married actually want to be
together
the marriage itself is not about love it
is about
interest a quirk marriage is also about
interest
but the focus is on creating offspring
with the best
possible quirks i think this quirk
marriage concept
is a good addition to the story because
realistically
if quirks were real in our own world
this type of marriage would
definitely be a thing it just feels real
and plausible within the context of that
world
and of course this type of marriage
comes with its own unique set of
challenges
and hardships and the perfect example of
this is the todoroki family itself
back in the present time dobby appears
to be resting after basically frying his
own body
over and over again during the big fight
in jakku
even though there hasn't been a lot of
public information coming out about
endeavour
since the jakku incident dobby knows
that his father
is not dead and dobby wouldn't want
endeavor to be dead anyway he is still
obsessed with getting his revenge on
endeavor
and making endeavour suffer in the worst
ways
possible just killing his father would
be too easy
and at this point it is clear that dobby
isn't just
targeting endeavor dobby intends to take
his whole family down with him
if that's what it takes to make
endeavors suffer
this means that every single member of
the todoroki family is in danger as a
direct result of
dobby's bloodthirsty obsession and
that is when we get the rest of dobby's
backstory and the real reason why toya
became a villain
back when dabi's true identity was
finally confirmed
i speculated that the reason why
endeavour stopped training dobby and
turned his attention to shoto
wasn't because he hated dobby or because
he thought dobby wasn't strong enough
it wasn't even because endeavour didn't
think that dobby was good enough to
surpass
all might in fact endeavor fully
acknowledged that dobby was stronger
than him
and that he did in fact have the
potential to surpass
all might but the specific way in which
endeavors and race quirks combined
within toya
led to a dangerous side effect although
he inherited his father's flame quirk
and although toya's flame quirk was
actually even stronger than endeavors
toya's body did not develop a sufficient
resistance to fire
instead his body inherited his mother's
ability to tolerate
extreme cold as a result every time toya
uses his fire based quirk
he inevitably burns his own body
even after realizing this endeavors
still believed that
toya could be the one to surpass all
might
but after rey and the other children
expressed their concern
that toya's training is going to kill
him endeavour finally agreed
that toya cannot be the one to surpass
all might
the risk to toyah himself would just be
too high
so endeavour makes this decision not
because he didn't like toya or because
he didn't believe in him
but because he cared about toya in his
own strange way
and he didn't want toya to continue
hurting himself after that
angie and rey decided to have more
children and eventually shoto was born
and he happened to have the perfect
combination of his parents fire and ice
quirks
however by that point toya already had
his heart set on becoming the future
number one pro hero
and surpassing all might endeavour had
already awakened
that dream within him and toyah didn't
want to give up on his life's dream now
just because using his quirk burned his
own body a little bit
toya wanted to keep training he wanted
to keep getting
stronger and he wanted to make his
father proud
so he kept coming home with burns and
bruises which were the direct result
of his training toya clearly wasn't
getting the message
so angie decided to try a tougher
approach
angie told toya to give up on the idea
of being a hero
and to just focus on other things like
his sister fuyumi
and his brother natsuo anji said this
for toya's
own good if toya gives up on being a
hero then he won't have to deal with a
lifetime of agony as he is forced to
burn himself
over and over again just so he could use
his quirk toya was committed to becoming
a hero
and he wanted nothing more than to
surpass all might
and make his father's dream come true so
when his own father told him to give it
up toya was crushed
this made him feel inadequate and
worthless and it made him jealous
of his brother shoto shoto was the one
whom angie was now placing all of his
faith in
instead of toya and this hurt toya so
much
because he still wanted to be the one to
make his father's dream come true
eventually all of this led toya to snap
desperate to get his father's attention
and to regain his favor
toya blew up at his family and tried to
hurt
baby shoto back in the hospital in the
present time
rey says to endeavor that he is not the
one who is in the most
pain the one who is in the most pain is
toyah
and this includes both physical and
psychological pain
neglected by his parents and forced to
give up on his lifelong dream
toya eventually lost it and this set him
down on the dark path of becoming a
murderous villain
this chapter was only the first part of
dobby's true
backstory so we can assume that the rest
of the story will be told
in the next chapter i assume that
endeavour stopped young toya from
hurting shoto and the other members of
the family
but what happened after that how did
toya
end up in a fire that made everyone
think that he was dead
my guess is that after he tried to hurt
shoto
toya was forcibly kept at a distance
because
after his outburst his family was now
afraid of him
feeling neglected and betrayed by his
own family toya probably decided to
train harder than he had ever trained
before
in order to prove everyone wrong at some
point
toya probably took his training too far
and he burned himself
badly in a massive fire of his own
making
after that he was presumed dead but he
wasn't really dead
so where did he go did he fake his own
death on purpose
and disappear or did someone else find
his injured body
and rescue him and if so did this person
who rescued toya
encourage him to become a villain or was
that toya's
own decision i'm super happy that we are
finally getting dobby's true backstory
the full version and i can't wait to
find out the rest of this
tragic tale definitely let me know what
you guys think
does this more complete version of the
story change how you feel about endeavor
now that we know that he didn't directly
push toya into training too hard and
that he actually wanted to protect toya
from the side effects of his own quirk
do you think that endeavour deserves
more sympathy from the mha
fanbase or do you think that endeavour's
obsession with surpassing
all might really did push toya into
becoming a villain
at least indirectly if not directly so
endeavour still deserves the hate that
he gets
finally what will happen to dobby now
where do we go from here can dobby be
redeemed in any way
or is he doomed to live out the rest of
his life as an
unrepentant psychotic villain despite
the fact that we are now
finally getting to see the human side of
dabi through this
backstory the fact remains that the
present day dobby definitely seems
committed to going straight to hell
and taking endeavour and possibly the
rest of his family down
with him but yeah crazy stuff and
definitely share your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
pocono hero content here on the channel
please leave a like it really does help
and if you're new here
or maybe you've been watching the videos
but you haven't had a chance to
subscribe
please make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram
at animeopror a big thank you to all of
our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord tuigo himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
liam thompson
al-jatal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
baked buddhist and tungsten tarcus
finally
thank you to all of our pro-hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky joe stanton
very gucci jessica calefon rathune
d'aura alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear
in our videos along with these legendary
people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you